in the UK in British English we say
Rooter for this thing that forwards data
that finds a route and we say rent it
for the woodworking tool that you make a
groove with in America they use the word
ranked in both it's the same
pronunciation for both gotcha and now I
believe routing is something completely
different in Australia but we don't have
to go up with another what happens if
there's a serious problem with routers
ultimately will mean that you can't get
your data through
so either you can't get your requests
through when you can't get the responses
back so it will stop you interacting
with the services you not be interact
with so you might notice that because
your web browsing and suddenly you can't
get somewhere you might notice that so
you can't get the Facebook for example
you might notice that because you start
receiving very poor performance so you
can still get through but everything
slows down a lot so what's going on
inside the routes and I suppose that's
there so I guess the way to think of it
is you've got a Rooter and so there's
going to be some data arriving some
stream of packets that are arriving into
one of these interfaces and the route
has to decide which of those packets are
going to go out here which of those
packets may be difficult to do and maybe
some of those packets are just going to
get drops and the routes not gonna know
what to do with them this is the in
interfacing these the out interfaces so
these would be mirrored yes you've got
you know this interface one two three
this would be one two three as well
selectors going in both directions on
each interface the route has to make
this decision about what should occur
must happen it should it drop it should
it forward it and if it's going to
forward it which intervation is fought
it out of and that's the process of
forwarding and the information it uses
to make those decisions is routing so
it's got to build up some information
that allows it to know that for this
given packet that's trying to get to
some destination IP address which one of
these interfaces is closer because these
are going to connect off to some other
router with some interfaces on and then
these are going to connect off to other
rooters and so at some point there's a
destination over here which is where you
want to get to and these routers have to
figure out okay this route it gets it in
those that it should go out of that
interface and not this interface because
this is going to go off somewhere else
and then when this route to gets it nice
no it's got to go out of that interface
and not this interface and so on and so
they all have to build up this
information and that's what the routing
protocols do is that these are protocols
have run so the route is exchanging
information in order
they can work out how to build the
tables they'll use for forwarding and
then when a packet actually comes in
that needs to be forwarded they look up
the destination address in that
forwarding table and they make a
decision on where to send it based on
the information that previously sorted
out through the region protocol
something like ibv 4 you've got 32-bit
addresses the destination address can be
approximately any bit pattern and so
you've got 2 to the 32 possible
destinations which is about 4 billion so
logically speaking each route or kind of
has a table with 4 billion entries in a
packet comes in you look at the
destination address in the table and
that says go out of interface 3 or guide
an interface to whatever it might be now
in practice that clearly would be a
stupid thing to do because a table of 4
billion entries big table to look
through every time and so there's ways
of that table is essentially compressed
by using what are called IP prefixes so
that instead of just having all the
possible addresses you say well ok let's
group the addresses together by some
prefix university of nottingham prefix
is one 28.24 3/16 so all the dresses on
the internet that begin one 28.24 3
belong to the universe you're not taking
and so a Rooter out there on the
internet will receive a packet this
destination is one 28.24 3.6 dot 7 or
something and it doesn't need to look up
exactly that address it just matches
that prefix this table of entries might
have dot 6.5 slash 24 it might have one
28.24 3/16 lots of different prefixes
and all of these are simply saying okay
well there's going to be some bit paths
of ones and zeros 1 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 I
think would be 1 2 8 and then the bit
pattern for 6 or lots of zeros and a one
10.5 start be again zeros 1 0 1 at the
end so it doesn't need to match any of
these remaining 8 bits and so it will go
down doing that and what it does is it
picks the longest prefix that matches so
you could have an entry here that was 1
28.24 3/16 slash 24 for example and it
might be that both of these entries
matched right so you had the address
that you're actually searching for let's
say it's 1 2 8 2 4 3 . 16.7
now that address
going to match both of these entries
because the prefix is the same so these
initial bits on the front are the same
and so what will be picked as it will be
this entry that's picked because that's
the longest prefix 24 bits is longer
than 16 bits so it's looking through
this to find the most specific because
it's most needed literally the most
specified subnet so they designate
ranges of IP addresses and what you're
trying to do is you're trying to find a
prefix that best matches the IP address
that you've got that you're looking for
the destination of and so you look
through this list and you'll find the
most specific which means the longest
prefix match and that's the subnet that
you're matching against the routier
would then essentially look at the
packet with with this as the destination
address it would look up in this table
it would say okay this matches here so
that's a possibility capes on the come
to the table o matches here this is the
best match so far looks for the rest
table this is still the best match so
this packet with this destination dress
gets sent out of interface on the wall
and that's how forwarding happens so
this is just software that's running on
them that's causing certain packets to
be transmitted so packets to be received
and interpreted in it's information
exchange between the rooters to build on
these 40 tables there's a couple of
standard ways that happens that the one
I personally find easiest to explain is
that you run a protocol that's called
the link state routing protocol and
what's essentially happening there is
the protocol runs and it attempts to
build a map of the network and then the
rooster can take this map and it can run
an algorithm called the shortest path
algorithm and it can find the shortest
path between any two points so then it
knows what to do if it gets a packet
coming in it Maps it to a destination
which it can then look up in this on
this map of the network and say right
what's the shortest path to get to that
destination so you'll have a bunch of
rooters in the network they'll be
connected in some configuration packet
comes in let's say to this one route
looks up in the forwarding table what it
needs to do with it and it says for
example this is the shortest path but
it's worked that out in advance by
having all of the routers inside this
network have been exchanging information
with each other as part of the routing
protocol so that they can construct this
map so if this packet comes in here and
it has to get out of here then this
router will know that the best way to
get down to here might be through this
guy which means it's got to go out of
this interface not this interface
obviously if that guy or something
failed along that if something crashes
there then yeah the routing protocol is
still running and it will detect
this guy's crash or detect that in
particular these links have failed and
so it will now say okay so now the
shortest path to get here is to come out
of this interface the three sort of bits
this process are there's a little
protocol that will run between two
routers on the link so they essentially
will exchange packets with each other
called hello packets and the idea there
is simply that if this guy can transmit
a packet to this one this guy receives
it transmits the packet back to say I've
received that and then this guy
transmits a packet back say and I
received your receipt if you like so
once they've made these exchanges they
both know that that link is live and
that somebody on the other end is
listening so they can both say right
well I know that this is route of 100 or
two they both know now that the link
between r1 to r2 and this will happen on
all of these links and so each router
builds up a set of information that says
what it's connected to
so that's kind of phase one and then
phase two is that this gets disseminated
I will try and spell this sermon
incorrectly probably get it wrong each
router now starts broadcasting to
everybody else this is what I'm
connected to and that gets disseminated
through the whole network so everyone
now knows what every other reader is
connected to and then each Rooter can
run the shortest path algorithm and each
router is trying to build up a
consistent set of data about the whole
network and then it runs an independent
computation part of the normal operation
of these is that when one of these links
fails let's say it's not the root of the
fails just this link fails there's a
time delay while this router and this
Rooter notice because they're
continually doing this hello exchange
and there are various different ways
that's going to shortcut but it could be
the case that if they have to wait until
they stop getting hello packets through
and I think the default configuration on
at least one of the instances of this
sort of protocol is that have to wait
for three exchanges to fail before they
decide that really the link is down they
then have to update the link state
database that they carry each one has to
update that and then they have to
disseminate that through the rest of the
network and so there's going to be a
period of time when this routes are here
still thinks that the shortest path is
to go write that because it's not yet
learnt from this guy that in fact this
link is gone for a period of time while
it's still detecting the link failure
then packets will still be being sent
down that link and I just get dropped
because they won't go anywhere so you'll
get some loss then for a period of time
after this has learnt about the link
failure it will send packets through so
the route so things will get sent to it
by mistake and it will have then send
them back somewhere else but you've got
this period of time where things are
inconsistent this is one of the things
that happens is that you get routing
loops so you'll have packets going
around this loop because they're both
disagreeing on what's there now
obviously it shouldn't last very long
you do get loops that last longer in
more complex configurations and this
kind of thing you'd expect that to be
resolved fairly quickly but you can get
these kind of loops occurring what you
then have is the problem of you've got
other networks if you have this sort of
protocol across the entire internet
you'd have a case where every routine
internet would have to know the status
of every single of the roots
friendliness net which would be many
many many hundreds of thousands if not
millions in particular what would kill
you there is that every time something
happened so a link failed every roots
are in the internet would have to be
informed of that before they could make
a consistent routing decision and so
what you actually have is you have a
different routing protocol and there is
only one instance of this called BGP
which runs between networks to allow
information to transit between networks
about what can be reached and its
problems in BGP that caused a lot of the
issues that you can't see reported about
this kind of things so for example does
complicated I think when YouTube has
gone offline and there was one a few
years ago when things the Pakistan
network operator they tried to inject
information into BGP to prevent people
connecting to YouTube from within their
network but because of the way they did
that that information propagated and it
caused lots of other networks to also
fail to be able to connect to YouTube it
comes back this prefix routing thing so
there's I don't know what the prefix
actually is it won't be this because
this is a private network space but
let's say it's 192.168 or slash 16 let's
say that's the YouTube prefix so it's
specified that the first 16 bits are
192.168 and then does matter what's
after that and that identifies the
YouTube network for the sake of argument
and so you've got this table that's been
built up in all the routers and when a
packet comes in trying to get to YouTube
the destination address gets matched it
matches against that prefix that says
which interface it should go out of and
it gets transmitted on so what they did
was they said okay well let's make it
one on two dot one six eight dot one two
8/17
and 192.168.1 two 7/17
think that covers space the point is
that they made it into two longer
prefixes
actually what should happen is that
should let's say go to YouTube they said
well what we'll do is we'll have these
addresses go to Devon all so we'll drop
those packets so instead of sending them
on to YouTube as we should when they
match against these prefixes in our
network we'll just drop the packet just
get rid of it which means that people
going through our network can't get to
YouTube unfortunately those prefixes got
advertised through BGP so they got
advertised other networks and other
networks picked them up as well and
because these are longer prefixes they
would be preferred to the shorter prefix
which was the right answer you prefer
these instead because they're long
prefixes so then other networks are
doing the same thing and they were
saying if they weren't really saying
that no they would be saying to the
Pakistan Network rather than going to
YouTube and so other networks start
believing these adverts the advertised
prefixes they match destination
addresses against that there should be
on to YouTube and they get sent to the
Pakistan now week instead and then those
things get dropped this bad information
got propagated out into the rest of the
Internet and that now starts to mean
that other people who connect to the
network through other people's networks
also start to see YouTube not being
reachable it was noticed this was a
problem and essentially all that has to
happen is that you don't believe these
two adverts and then this one takes over
again and you tube becomes reachable
again with BGP you can apply routing
policies so you can start to say things
like I can reach these networks but I'd
prefer that you didn't use me to get
there or you know I can reach these but
our contract says that you should use
these others in preference or you should
use me in preference for these different
things or when you re advertise that you
can now reach these networks because you
can get to them through me you have to
advertise them in such and such a way or
would like you to advertising in such in
such a way so that not everybody in the
world tries to come through me that I'm
like I'm a last resort the backup link
or whatever it might be so you can start
to apply its kind of more complex
configurations to how this information
gets disseminated whereas in this case
with its like link state routing it
really is just a case of detect what you
connect it to tell everybody else what
you connect it to run shortest paths and
that's it
but so these numbers get assigned
hierarchy so there's a body called I
Anna the internet assigned numbers
Authority I think